kag sanoussi lé président de l'institut
international de gestion des conflits
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france est ce qu'il
faut craindre réellement une tentative
de coup d'état en centrafrique mais tout
à fait ils font la craindre parce que
nous savons comment les choses se
passent
et malheureusement comment ça finit
aulas a pas fait quelques uns des cas
connu la guerre avec des conséquences
énormes
la population est donc on doit les
initions aucun effort ou enrayer la
vague de violence qui démarre avec une
coalition hétéroclite à la fois même
insensé des cookies et elle s'était
opposée qui aujourd'hui se mettre
ensemble pour mettre en péril la
démocratie
le démarrage de la vie il faut qu'il se
fasse une bande démocratique
s'il ya des conditions c'est dans les
urnes qui font les exposés mais pas en
temps pour prendre des armes
nous avons travaillé dans ce pays nous
avons vu comment le pays est super voilà
pourquoi je pense que il voit absolument
individuel à à tous les points de vue et
anticipée alors vous savez qu'il y a un
nom qui circule soupçonné d'être
derrière ces tentatives de
déstabilisation il s'agit de françois
bozizé l'ancien président renversé en
2013 on le rappelle par les ex c'est les
cas de michel d'auto déjà on l'a
entendue dans le sujet les groupes armés
qui s'organise parmi ces groupes armés
et à des milices antibalas cas
qui serait proche de françois bozizé que
faut-il penser de tout cela c'est
quelque chose qu'ils meublé table parce
qu'on sait l'opposition joue de qui
pénètre les dirigeants politiques
l'ancien principal barqûq vous disais et
actuel françois est le monsieur temps
dira il n'empêche que s'il bozizé et
s'impliquer dans cette île à vegas et
fois regrettable parce que il a déjà
fait un coup d'état
et aujourd'hui il est arrivé souvenez
vous quand ils arrivent en centrafrique
je pense que le musée touadéra qu'aurait
dû des concerts une opération pour qu'il
va arrêter ce qui n'a pas été fait je
pense dans un esprit d'apaisement et
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que ce soit
une bonne chose que monsieur bozizé pu
se retrouver dans une situation d'une
nouvelle rébellion
j'espère en tout cas que le bon sens va
venir en centre-ville ou que le débat
démocratique prennent le dessus parce
que si les mains va se reproduire ce
serait dommage et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec un l'alliance a
plaisanté baraka est tel qu'on peut le
dire blanche posée et laissez les cas
les anciens syndicats c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour le peuple sans
parler d'elle et il est important qu'un
la loi se fasse autorité et pour que les
uns les autres de gros viennent à de
bons sentiments courante est vraiment
dans le combat démocratique
c'est peut-être le fait aussi que sa
gamme d'ati soir et refusées par la cour
constitionnelle dessus des raisons qui
ont été évoquées ce sont pas des raisons
farfelues mais je pense qu'il a joué le
jeu il a dit qu'il acceptait et
aujourd'hui c'est triste de constater
que on risque de le voir encore dans une
rébellion
j'espère que ça va pas aller loin et que
l'opposition de la muscade et des forces
de défense et on a vu qu'elle va faire
en sorte que les uns les autres en
revenir à de bons sentiments pour éviter
surtout à la population parce que
n'oubliez pas c'est la population savoir
que quelqu'un leur premier avec steam
est il important de la préserver
alors comment en est on arrivé là
depuis la transition l'élection de
faustin archange touadéra la tête du
pays
c'est vrai vous faisiez allusion à la
minus qu'à la mission onusienne qui est
présente en république centrafricaine
depuis des années
après la guerre civile comment est-ce
qu'on en arrive là aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il ya des groupes armés qui occupent
encore les deux tiers du territoire
centrafricain
vous savez lespinasse convenant au
niveau de l'apc que la paix une démarche
similaire il ya un accord de paix la
mise à jour est délicate parce que comme
népal équilibre des forces vers lui que
l'armée centrafricaine a commencé à se
reconstruire
quand par tant d'émotions quand vous
êtes désavantagés sur le plan d'un coût
de la france vous l'avez pas les mêmes
éléments
et donc aujourd'hui des noms se
détachent vraiment maintenant pas
appliquer concrètement et je pense que
le choix de mets en 3d a été de ne pas
faire la guerre pour amener la paix
certains critiques que ce choix c'est
entendable mais on peut pas faire la
guerre pour amener la paix est donc
aujourd'hui à l'accord qui a été signé
la mise en oeuvre n'a pas été sincère de
par celle des acteurs et nous avons les
conséquences aujourd'hui parce que vous
pas oublier que la guerre est aussi une
vente parce que la guerre était arrivée
ces textes sont enrichis ont développé
des affaires et la paix et quelque chose
il ya leur empêcher les empêcher
d'accéder à celle qui s est donc
continuons à la fin mon n'y a pas
tellement et je pense que le 15
l'appétit du gain est quelque chose qui
a fondamentalement athlètes mais aussi
il faut un bonheur qui a déjoué position
politique parce que quand c'est la
politique chacun a envie d'être à la
place du chef celui et barbares parce
que c'est un jeu politique est normal
mais il faut utiliser les armes
démocratique
aujourd'hui beaucoup de tartans coeur se
sont accumulés malheureusement alors que
nous sommes là dans la dynamique et
d'apaisement des coeurs et des amas de
coeur voilà pourquoi je pense que après
l'accord malgré les efforts fait de
parler d'autres nous ont entre un point
mais la paix n'est pas totale à son
profit il ya un effort considérable qui
est fait si nous avons aujourd'hui d'une
élection présidentielle avec trois ex
présidents qui se présentait merci
monsieur bozizé avec la foulée par la
conventionnelle ya quand même en
s'imposant qui est candidate
le président sortant donc c'est déjà une
vitalité démocratique et ça c'est
quelque chose d'assez particulier qu'il
faut sur vinassan profiter voilà
pourquoi je pense qu'il faut continuer
dans cette dynamique préserver les
élections pour que un candidat cumule
quant à saute et le 27 décembre pour
conduire a conçu la paix 6e
pour conclure et la corde cartoon signé
en 2019 avec la fille du soudan et de la
russie beaucoup le jugent cet accord pas
suffisamment inclusif
vous pensez que c'est le cas non je ne
crois pas que ce soit le cas c'est un
accord qui n'étaient pas mauvaises mais
un accord n'est pertinent quoi comment
il admis ont des revendications des
conditions de décembre c'est l'accord
qui n'est pas mauvais il est bon mais la
mise en oeuvre n'a pas été et pour les
ducasses à tous les coins de rue pascal
beaucoup de gros cage et cet accord là
je pense qu'il est particulièrement bien
dans un brésil
la mise en scène est difficile quand
vous savez la négociation pour la paix
vous savez que c'est une oeuvre de
longue haleine et il faut avoir de la
patience dont ce n'est pas en deux jours
que les choses au fond qu'il faut
persévérer pourquoi les gens reviennent
à la raison
c'est ce que nous espérons pour la leçon
merci beaucoup à vous quelques fans si
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
de l'institut international de gestion
des conflits chien